bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
vous Nicolas Baverel bonsoir bonsoir
économiste et historien vous publiez
démocratie contre empire autoritaire aux
éditions de l'Observatoire c'est un
essai qui analyse en profondeur la
grande confrontation à l'oeuvre et
depuis longtemps entre l'occident d'un
côté la Russie et la Chine de l'autre
nous avons des ennemis et nous avons
trop tardé à les voir comme tel nous
dites-vous en substance on va y venir
mais tout n'est pas perdu vous restez
optimiste et on peut sauver nos valeurs
les valeurs de la liberté politique on
en parle longuement tout à l'heure mais
on commence ce soir avec un rapport choc
celui de la commission d'enquête de la
filière française sur le nucléaire un
curry dérive des
divagations pardonnez-moi divagation
l'émo sont forts divagation politique
les députés ils accablent les décisions
des pouvoirs publics sur les 30
dernières années et ils essayent de
tirer les leçons des erreurs passées
alors comment retrouver
indépendance et souveraineté énergétique
c'est notre grand débat ce soir avec nos
invités avant de retrouver à 20h15 les
parties pris de nos affranchis et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu ce
soir vous me suivez Nicolas baveray
merci et bien c'est parti
[Musique]
des décisions prises à l'envers une
lente dérive un effarant cocktail
d’ignorance de cynisme de naïveté ou de
démagogie ça fait beaucoup rarement un
rapport parlementaire n'aura été aussi
cinglant pour pointer les erreurs qui
ont conduit à la perte de souveraineté
d'indépendance énergétique de notre pays
bonsoir Antoine Armand bonsoir c'est
vous le rapporteur de cette commission
d'enquête vous êtes député renaissance
de Haute-Savoie et vous avez égrainé les
erreurs commises sur les 30 dernières
années lors d'une conférence de presse
on enverra quelques extraits c'était à
la mi-journée à l'Assemblée bonsoir
anne-laureblin merci d'être là vous êtes
député les républicains du
Maine-et-Loire la droite a aussi sa part
dans la perte de souveraineté dans les
années 2000-2010 on en dira un mot
bonsoir Julie la ernus et bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes député Europe
Écologie Les Verts de Loire-Atlantique
vous êtes membre de cette commission
d'enquête mais vous n'avez pas voté ce
rapport vous ne cautionnez pas ces
conclusions vous nous direz pourquoi
enfin bonsoir Géraldine wesner grande
spécialiste du dossier nucléaire que
vous suivez entre autres pour le journal
Le Point Nicolas baveray évidemment
intervenait quand vous le souhaitez dans
ce débat vous connaissez aussi ces
questions énergétiques alors que dit-il
précisément ce rapport il a deux
secondes pas facile pour nous le résumer
le chrono de Blacko pour commencer
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
ces femmes bonsoir
alors ce rapport j'étais un peu émue ce
qui n'arrive pas souvent quand on
regarde LCP mais moi j'étais un peu le
chafouin après les débats sur la réforme
des retraites chahut un peu façon
Hanouna ça me déplaisait pas et ce matin
j'ai vu que les représentants du peuple
ou la nation comme vous voudrez était
capable de se mettre d'accord sur les
sujets extrêmement importants peut-être
même le sujet le plus important donc pas
la réforme des retraites mais la
souveraineté énergétique de notre pays
regardez comme c'était beau vous voyez
sur la gauche de l'écran le LR slenderg
qui a voté l'ascension du gouvernement
borne qui cherche le relèvement à la
main Antoine Armand qui est là ce soir
et qui lui a voté pour la réforme des
retraites donc il y a eu vraiment un
vote très favorable sur ce rapport 31
membres deux voix contre qui
représentaient les écologistes et les
insoumis alors c'est bien sûr impossible
de résumer un rapport de 400 pages en
200 secondes donc je ne vais pas réussir
à le faire mais si je devais essayer je
dirais qu'il y a trois erreurs commis
ises dans le passé qu'on doit éditer de
reproduire si possible donc la première
ça serait avant de prendre une décision
politique ça serait bien de consulter
sérieusement et les scientifiques et les
industriels qui sont concernés par la
question et le meilleur exemple de
d'erreur qui a plus de Camille dans le
passé commise pardon dans le passé c'est
bien sûr le choix de supprimer 24
réacteurs prise par François Hollande la
version d'Arnaud Montebourg on écoute
l'accord était présenté par Martine
Aubry à l'époque comme un changement de
société et par ces signes Duflot comme
une rupture historique bon pour moi
c'est un accord de cuantables c'est à
dire qu'on s'est mis d'accord sur un
marqueur politique avec ma manière à
marquer les esprits et on s'est retrouvé
avec un programme qui expliquait qu'il
fallait fermer 24 réacteurs
et après
et ben vogue la galère
évoque la guerre alors cela dit pas de
Hollande bashing ou pas trop en tout cas
parce que vous savez bien que la
politique doivent tenir compte de
l'opinion or en 2011 c'était Fukushima
et donc forcément la cote du nucléaire
avait sérieusement plongée mais ça nous
rappelle que l'émotion doit pas
forcément prendre le pas sur la raison
même aujourd'hui regardez Sandrine
Rousseau dit elle-même que on est
souvent trop rationnel en politique
peut-être par provocation et moi je
préfère les sorcières plutôt que les
ingénieurs mais c'est pas juste rigolo
regardez les jeunes quand on fait des
sondages il y a une majorité de jeunes
qui sont convaincus que le nucléaire
produit autant de CO2 que le gaz et le
charbon donc si déjà nous regardent ils
sont pas nombreux mais s'il y a des gens
qui nous regardent je leur dis c'est
faux voilà donc ça c'est si on peut
essayer de vrai un petit peu pour pour
la chose la deuxième erreur à ne pas
reproduire si possible c'est de jeter
des belles idées en l'air sans se
soucier de la manière dont on les
réalise concrètement donc de manière
industrielle exemple leur renouvelable
vraiment une super idée genre c'est pas
moi qui dirait du mal de ça sauf que
aujourd'hui bah presque la des panneaux
solaires sont fabriqués en Chine et ça
au point de vue de la souveraineté
forcément c'est un petit peu moyen donc
il faut créer des filières industrielles
en France et donc Antoine Armand
peut-être par provocation disait
attention regardez on a total chez nous
une entreprise très populaire qui fait
des plateformes de forage flottantes et
si ils faisaient des éoliennes
flottantes est-ce que ça serait pas une
bonne idée bah écoutez-le
si 50 par éolien permettent d'améliorer
considérablement notre production à
court terme j'entends à moins de 15 ans
et donc à moins de 10 ans en particulier
il faut qu'on puisse réduire voir
supprimer les procédures de concertation
et de délibération qui ne sont pas
absolument essentiels à la qualité
technique du projet et à la préservation
de l'environnement bon j'imagine que
vous n'êtes pas très contente en
entendant ça mais tout le monde doit se
remettre en cause dans ce dossier la
troisième erreur c'est la dernière que
je vais vous citer à ne pas commettre
c'est de faire une confiance aveugle à
l'Europe je sais bien que on a longtemps
pensé que ceux qui critiquait l’europe
était forcément des populistes bah vous
voyez aujourd'hui même un Européen
convaincu comme Antoine Normandie non
sur la question de l'énergie on ne peut
pas payer l'électricité pas cher qu'on a
grâce au nucléaire au prix du gaz la
France doit passer avant l'Europe en
écoute
je le dis en tant que député
profondément pro-européen nous ne
pouvons plus nous ne devons plus
accepter un cadre européen qui
désavantage la France et qui va à
l'encontre de ses intérêts vitaux donc
comme prévu c'était complètement
impossible de résumer
pour vous lancer le débat regardez ça
c'est ce qui nous attend c'est le mur
énergétique c'est à dire que si on prend
pas très vite des décisions on fonce
dedans mais vous êtes là pour en
débattre mais on espère que on va pas on
va pas aller jusque là merci beaucoup
Stéphane on va continuer à parler du
diagnostic parce qu'il y a aussi des
propositions pour pour l'avenir Antoine
Armand on parle énormément des années
Holland ce serait la période la plus
grave d'erreur commise etc mais pas
seulement il y a 30 ans d'un curry et si
on remonte à la décennie à la fin des
années 90 début 2000 jusqu'à 2010 il y a
dix années de perdu expliquer nous ça
oui il me semble que ce que les
auditions ont très bien montré c'est que
cette décennie de la fin des années 1990
au début des années 2010 c'est une
décennie de grande latences où nous ne
mettons pas en place des filières pour
développer les énergies renouvelables ou
produits
un petit peu plus d'électricité qu'on en
consomme on l'exporte c'est très bien et
donc on est victime de ce que j'appelle
une illusion sur capacitaire on croit
que finalement on n'aura pas besoin de
plus d'électricité dans le futur alors
que nous sommes déjà conscients de
l'importance de réussir la transition
écologique et donc les filières
industrielles en matière d'énergie
renouvelable ne sont pas développées sur
notre continent européen nos outils de
maîtrise de la demande d'efficacité de
sobriété énergétique ne sont pas
développés l'anticipation de la
prolongation des centrales n'est pas
anticipée alors que tenez-vous bien en
1991 un rapport de lopex l'Office
Parlementaire scientifique dit attention
il y aura un effet falaise tous nos
réacteurs devront être renouvelés en
même temps
et nous nous retrouvons donc à la fin de
ces années 2000 avec ce retard déjà
accumulé
en question c'est la droite au pouvoir
Sarkozy il y a eu des erreurs de commise
aussi dans ces années-là mais en fait ce
travail qui a été souhaité par les
députés les républicains parce que c'est
nous qui avons demandé cette commission
d'enquête visait justement à regarder
les choses de manière objective et pour
anticiper justement et permettre de se
corriger il y a effectivement peut-être
à l'époque un certain nombre de
difficultés d'anticipation des exemples
dans le rapport arrêt de super Phénix
qui font qui aurait permis à la France
de gagner ça c'est les années Jospin
mais moi ce que je retiens surtout c'est
pour demain et quand je vois les
chiffres que Blacko nous a donné tout à
l'heure sur ce que croit aujourd'hui les
Français sur l'énergie nucléaire moi ce
que j'observe c'est qu'il y a
aujourd'hui beaucoup de désinformations
et en tant que parlementaire aux
responsabilités
en tout cas élue au Parlement nous avons
et nous devons cette vérité aux Français
que de dire que le nucléaire est une
énergie décarbonée que nous ne pouvons
pas nous priver du nucléaire que le tout
énergies renouvelable et purement et il
y a un tournant dans l'opinion massif
qui je ne croise une prise parce que sur
notamment le soleil le développement
massif du soleil
on a une vraie un vrai manque
d'information sur effectivement
l'origine et ça a été dit très justement
sur l'origine de la fabrication de ces
panneaux solaires et moi je regrette
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y ait pas eu et tous
les Français l'entendent d'ailleurs très
bien d'abord cette initiative du
gouvernement de développer le plan de
programmation énergétique nous avons
commencé à examiner à l'automne le plan
énergies renouvelable nous venons de
terminer à peine la question du
nucléaire et seulement à l'automne nous
verrons la plante là vous vous projetez
vers l'avenir on va y venir mais il
faudrait qu'on reste que c'est quasiment
200 pages qui décrivent quand même 30
ans d'un curry le gros du gros c'est ce
fameux accord électoral François
Hollande signée en 2011 on est après la
primaire Martine Aubry Cécile Duflot
d'un côté François de l'autre avec des
circonscriptions en jeu et un programme
notamment en matière énergétique pas
plus de 50% de nucléaire d'ici à 2025
dans le mix électrique avec le recul
Julie danous est-ce que vous resigneriez
cet accord-là
et laquelle aujourd'hui on est dépendant
à 60 70 % de l'énergie nucléaire en
France on savait que les centrales
allaient vieillir
on voit aujourd'hui les problématiques
de la compatibilité entre le nucléaire
et le changement climatique notamment en
matière d'eau et on avait besoin même
Emmanuel Macron l'avait annoncé au début
de son quinquennat de diversifier nos
sources d'approvisionnement pour la
dépendance énergétique et la
souveraineté quelle énergie la meilleure
c'est celle qu'on ne consomme pas et
donc on aurait dû et ça faisait aussi
par ces petites de cet accord électoral
mettre des investissements massifs sur
la rénovation énergétique et thermique
des bâtiments ainsi que sur les
transports ça c'est un premier point que
je trouve on n'a pas assez observé alors
que ça faisait un retard le deuxième le
deuxième élément mais vous me répondez
pas sur les 50% je vous réponds en fait
le deuxième élément de cet accord
électoral sur les 50% c'était diversifié
notre mix électrique pourquoi parce que
en France et Nathalie kochisco-morizet
la dip pendant une des auditions on a
fait le Grenelle de l'environnement on
n'a pas parlé à cette occasion du
nucléaire pourtant tous les fonds du
Grenelle sur l'énergie sont allés sur le
nucléaire la France est le seul pays qui
n'est pas en capacité d'atteindre ses
objectifs en matière d'énergie
renouvelable pourquoi on l'a vu et on a
pu l'observer et moi j'en tire ces
conclusions là de ces heures d'audition
que cette opposition en France entre
l'investissement public dans le
nucléaire et dans les énergies
renouvelles fait aujourd'hui qu'on a un
retard on a un retard qui fait en sorte
qu'on fait face à une difficulté
grandissante puisqu'on a tout misé sur
le nucléaire et donc notre souveraineté
et notre indépendance elle est remise en
question et puis la dernière question
l'objectif des 50% n'ont pas fait
accélérer les onls les énergies en fait
la problématique qui ont l'air très bien
vu c'est que en réalité quand on voit et
l'audition Arnaud Montebourg que vous
avez vu la France est le n'a pas
réellement mis en place les politiques
publiques pour permettre d'atteindre cet
objectif c'était pas juste une question
de fermer des réacteurs puisque on avait
un parc existant un défaut
d'anticipation de planification
d'augmenter la part des énergies
renouvelables et c'est ça qu'on n'a pas
réussi à faire et pas créer les filières
industriels puisqu'on a tout misé sur le
nucléaire sur cet accord ce qui marque
dans le rapport c'est qu'il ne s'appuie
sur aucune étude d'impact scientifique
et que de manière générale la place des
techniciens des scientifiques dans la
décision politique est quasi absente
elle est totalement absente et on
l'entend encore ce soir c'est que les
Français et une très grande partie de la
classe politique en réalité y compris
Emmanuel Macron a découvert il y a
quelques mois à l'occasion de la crise
énergétique que remplacer du nucléaire
du pilotable par des renouvelables
intermittents ça ne marchait pas on a eu
un anticyclone pas de vent la nuit pas
de soleil et simplement le système
s'effondre je vous garantis que de très
nombreux politiques ont fait une
découverte à cette occasion et là on
revient aussi aux années Sarkozy il y a
une espèce de grande confusion qui s'est
installée dans l'esprit à la fois des
politiques et des français quand on a
fait le Grenelle de l'environnement
justement on a invité toutes les ONG
écolo et anti-nucléaires autour de la
table et on a mis dans la tête des gens
l'idée que sortir du nucléaire c'était
agir pour le climat ce qui n'a rien à
voir agir pour le climat ma soirée était
justement de développer le nucléaire en
même temps qu'on développait fortement
les énergies renouvelables et toutes les
énergies renouvelables d'ailleurs et
également thermique dont vous parlez
très bien dans votre rapport si bien
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve face non
seulement à une classe politique et des
gens qui n'ont pas encore complètement
compris ces notions complexes et un mur
qu'on voyait venir encore une fois
depuis depuis le premier jour depuis le
lancement du parc nucléaire on sait ce
qui va se passer Nicolas baveray vous
êtes consterné aussi quand vous voyez
c'est ce ces erreurs commises ou vous
dites quand même on est un tournant il y
a une prise de conscience et maintenant
on va planifier là où on peut
effectivement être consterné c'est que
si on regarde l'histoire dans les années
70 on a réussi à mobiliser et de manière
assez prémonitoire à construire un
système énergétique qui était d'abord
qui assurait aux citoyens une énergie
abondante et bon marché qui était un
vrai facteur de compétitivité pour
l'économie et qui assurer notre
indépendance énergétique et à la suite
des erreurs qui ont été mentionnées on
se retrouve aujourd'hui avec des
citoyens qui sont étranglés par des
factures qui explosent et avec des
conséquences y compris politiques sur le
développement de l'extrémisme on se
retrouve avec des entreprises qui sont
exemple et non un certain nombre vont
disparaître alors que EDF plus
effectivement l'entreprise à qui on a
fait porter par une partie du poids du
bouclier de manière d'ailleurs
complètement irrégulière parce que
l'État n'avait aucun droit de mettre à
la charge de cette entreprise
c'est ces sommes mais enfin bref donc au
delà d'EDF il y a quand même des pas
entiers de l'industrie française qui
sont soit à l'arrêt et des artisans qui
sont dans des situations désespérées
enfin sur le plan de l'indépendance on
est obligé d'importer à prix fort de
l'électricité et dernière chose en plus
c'est vrai que le nucléaire est
décarboné et que
l'électricité qu'on importe et de vient
principalement d'Allemagne et le tiers
est produit avec du charbon ce qui est
une catastrophe écologique donc ça c'est
la situation qu'on a réussi à fabriquer
le système est complètement fou alors
maintenant c'est vrai il faut repartir
sur les erreurs commises et puis il faut
essayer avec la difficulté que les
systèmes énergétiques c'est des gros
beau et donc la durée d'investissement
précisément ce qu'on a raté maintenant
il faut et corriger sur tous les erreurs
intellectuelles et la principale c'est
que on a eu on a raisonné j'allais dire
énergie par énergie et avec cette idée
effectivement que le nucléaire c'était
le diable et que les renouvelables
c'était mais on a oublié que notre
ennemi ce qui nous fait mourir c'est pas
le nucléaire c'est le carbone et donc il
faut reprendre tout ça avec deux choses
premièrement il y aura pas diminution de
la consommation on doit faire des
économies mais l'idée par ailleurs de
planifier 20% de baisse de la
consommation d'électricité alors qu'on
veut passer à la voiture électrique avec
il la demande va exploser c'est un
énorme mensonge donc il faut sortir du
mensonge voilà on sent qu'il y a encore
un correction de lunettes à faire pour
terminer sur le diagnostic moi je suis
absolument en contradiction totale il y
a deux choses qui peuvent mettre un
terme à la vie sur Terre le
réchauffement climatique et le nucléaire
vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez le
nucléaire une catastrophe nucléaire
c'est et donc croire que l'une va sauver
l'autre et relève de l'imposture il y a
à un moment donné ce n'est pas de
l'imposture intellectuelle moi je suis
inquiète j'aimerais croire comme des
millions de lobby nucléaires le véhicule
qui a une solution magique qui
permettrait de sortir des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et qui permettrait
de maintenir notre niveau de vie
actuelle ça n'est simplement pas le cas
toutes les questions qu'on a posé sur la
filière du nucléaire sur la gestion des
déchets sur la compatibilité avec le
réchauffement climatique et les
ressources en eau disponibles le fiasco
du nucléaire et ça a été vu dans la
Commission
le père de Flamanville sait-on
construire un nouvel EPR sait-on
construire vous répondez parce que vous
les connaissez les griefs qui sont
portés au nucléaire
on voulait vraiment revenir sur toute la
filière madame lernous qui représente
élevé est très signif parce qu'en
quelques secondes on a eu un concentré
d'histoire et de contre-vérité première
contre vérité le nucléaire est en mesure
de mettre fin à l'humanité ça n'a aucun
sens scientifique ça n'a aucun sens
scientifique ce que vous dites je vous
invite à faire la distinction entre
l'énergie nucléaire civile et militaire
on pourra parler enrichissement si vous
voulez donc c'est totalement faux
deuxième chose vous l'avez dit mais je
pensais même plus que depuis Dominique
Voynet on disait ça aujourd'hui en
France vous avez dit je préfère le
carbone au nucléaire vous venez de le
dire vous venez de dire si je dois
choisir je préfère le carbone nucléaire
dernière chose vous avez parlé vous avez
parlé de l'eau sur le nucléaire et l'eau
viennent d'être mise à jour
il y a une grande partie des réacteurs
qui sont en circuit ouvert et qui donc
ne font que prélever de l'eau et la
rendre très rapidement en souvent en
plus d'un point de vue maritime
c'est-à-dire de la mer à la mer donc
l'impact de température est faible
et vous avez des centrales en circuit
dit fermé qui consomment une partie de
l'eau 12% et non plus 40% et ces
chiffres sont en train d'être révisés et
vous voyez Géraldine buzzler lui disait
tout à l'heure si on n'est pas capable
collectivement après 150 heures de
diction de regarder en face des faits
scientifiques des réalités techniques
des contraintes industrielles nous
n'avons aucune chance de réaliser ce qui
est un objectif et je finis là-dessus
puisque nous avons que la chance d'avoir
une collaborer sur le plateau qu'est-ce
que c'est le la liberté est un combat
pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut de la
souveraineté énergétique pourquoi est-ce
que je propose dans le rapport un
inventaire minier pour qu'on dispose de
matériaux critiques pour les énergies
renouvelables sur notre territoire parce
que demain parce que demain nous a un
problème
photovoltaïques dans les mains de la
Chine alors j'aurais voulu qu'on termine
le diagnostic parce que vous avez voilà
le courage comme député de la majorité
de reconnaître que les années Macron
n'ont pas été parfaite non plus
Géraldine la fermeture de Fessenheim
n'était pas une fatalité vous écrivez
noir sur blanc pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
a amené autant de temps à réagir alors
qu'il faudra appeler l'été à l'Elysée il
était secrétaire général de l'Elysée il
était plutôt pro-nucléaire et ça a mis
du temps au nucléaire oui mais non je
pense pas je pense qu'en fait il fait
aussi partie de cette génération de
politique qui s'est complètement
désintéressée de ces sujets techniques
technologiques et industriels ça n'était
pas son sujet ça n'est pas dans son SCOP
il a cru parce qu'on le lui disait
qu'effectivement il suffirait de
développer des renouvelables beaucoup
qu'on ferait des interconnexions avec
les voisins et que finalement tout irait
pour le mieux il a réellement découvert
je pense le sujet assez tardivement et
ça pose la question de que vous posez
très bien que vous soulevez très bien
dans le rapport et qui avait soulevé
dans une audition qui était saisissante
Yves Brechet qui a été au commissaire à
l'énergie atomique pendant 6 ans de
mandat entre 2012 et 2018 une brechait
il est pas reçu par
tu réaliste à l'origine de cette
situation une directive européenne pour
ouvrir à la concurrence le marché de la
production d'électricité pour rester
l'unique exploitant de ces réacteurs
nucléaires l'entreprise publique doit
donc partager sa rente le monopole de DF
devait être corrigé selon Bruxelles le
problème c'est que Bruxelles
conscient de ça a introduit les pilules
empoisonnées pour empêcher EDF de
s'imposer sur le marché un rapport
parlementaire publié en 2021 estime que
la reine est en partie responsable de
l'affaiblissement d'EDF mais pour le
gouvernement le dispositif a aussi un
avantage il constitue une protection
face à la hausse des prix de
l'électricité la reine c'est un des
mécanismes qui permet que les
consommateurs français ménagent
collectivités entreprises puissent
bénéficier de ce coût de production bas
l'année dernière en pleine crise
énergétique le gouvernement avait obligé
EDF à vendre davantage d'électricité à
bas prix assez concurrents une décision
contestée par le groupe mais jugé légal
par le Conseil d'État
vous soutenez cette proposition est-ce
que c'est elle est même possible on peut
suspendre il faudrait que le
gouvernement le décide mais c'est ce que
ce moyen de tarifier de tarifs réguliers
aux concurrents de DF c'est ce que nous
avons demandé et s'il y a un combat à
mener à l'Europe c'est celui-ci
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas possible que on
se servent et on utilise ce système sur
le dos de l'entêtement de DF et moi
quand j'ai auditionné le nouveau
président d'EDF c'est une question très
précise que je lui ai posé savoir s'il
était capable avec le gouvernement avec
le président de la République de tenir
tête à l'Europe pour que nous puissions
avoir une énergie qui soit à tarif
acceptable et qui en tout cas ne soit
pas en deçà de ce que l'on produit alors
il y a deux sujets c'est très technique
Géraldine gosner pour faire de la
pédagogie on fixe le tarif de
l'électricité en indexant sur le gaz ça
c'est le niveau européen aujourd'hui
parce que les voilà on gagnait ce
rapport de force il y a une expérience
il faut il faut pas dire allez-y où est
son contraire le marché
de l'électricité en Europe a bien
évidemment été construit avec la France
pourquoi la France était d'accord sur ce
mécanisme là parce qu'il pouvait
revendre son électricité nucléaire qu'il
prodigeait à moindre coût un coup
beaucoup plus élevé assez pays voisins
donc EDF et la France ont largement
profité de ce système et de ce mécanisme
européen aujourd'hui la question de la
reine c'est la manière dont l'État
français a trouvé pour répondre à la
question de la libéralisation du marché
de sujets différents
on les a fait au doigt mouillés un peu
comme l'ouverture de Flamanville alors
Géraldine Wessner là dessus et puis
Antoine Armand suspendre
c'est une évidence de suspendre la reine
et ça pour les raisons qui expliquaient
Henri Poggio et qu'on expliquait tous
les patrons d'EDF enfin il y avait une
belle unanimité là-dessus simplement par
principe le principe même de dire à un
producteur d'électricité donc en
l'occurrence EDF tu vas financer tu vas
payer tes concurrents pour qu'ils
existent c'est une aberration je veux
dire c'est on dit que c'est une
libéralisation du marché je sais pas
comment ça s'appelle
EDF était un monopole
effectivement mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi reconnaître à un moment que le
l'énergie c'est le sang d'un pays c'est
un élément vital d'une nation ça ne peut
pas être considéré comme un autre bien
ça n'est pas donc ça veut dire que ça
n'est pas une marchandise qu'on peut
soumettre
de ça dépend la survie d'une société et
d'ailleurs l'Allemagne le sait
l'Allemagne qui n'a eu de cesse que de
faire en sorte que l'avantage compétitif
que représentait français soit brisé via
les règles
que vous êtes et vous aurez le mot de la
fin toi en Armand allez-y rapidement
l'erreur parce que l'idée du marché
européen elle est loin d'être idiote
c'est-à-dire que le fait d'avoir des
interconnexions normalement ça peut
participer de la sécurité énergétique
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait comme erreur
première erreur on s'est intéressé
uniquement à baisser les prix pour le
consommateur personne n'a regardé les
problèmes de production et on s'est
retrouvé en sous-production deuxièmement
l'idée du du prix c'est effectivement ce
qu'on appelle le primarginal qui est sur
la dernière installation qu'on met en
route et effectivement c'était le gars
c'était le gaz pourquoi parce que tout
ce système était adossé et ça c'est vrai
que c'était les Allemands qu'il y avait
beaucoup pesé là-dessus sur le gaz russe
bon et donc on a mis en place deux
j'allais dire deux pièges dans les qui
nous ont été tra premier piège qui est
que on s'est retrouvé en sous-capacité
de production massive et avec des
problèmes effectivement créés par les
renouvelables puisque c'est un Thermomix
complètement et on a laissé à Vladimir
Poutine
la liberté de fixer le prix du gaz en
plus de d'avoir une
société
de l'uranium enrichit vient de rue c'est
moins de 16% vos chiffres sont pas
exacts les chiffres de Greenpeace ils ne
sont pas égaux pour terminer ce débat
vous l'aurez le débat sur la question
nucléaire et russes
on va terminer ce débat avec vous
Antoine Armand est-ce que Bruno Le Maire
a une chance de se faire entendre à
Bruxelles il a son bâton de pèlerin sur
cette question là depuis déjà plusieurs
mois ça n'avance pas la proposition de
la Commission européenne et dans le bon
sens la question est il faut se la poser
dans l'autre sens c'est nous sommes
parlementaires qui avons vocation à
porter la souveraineté énergétique du
pays la France porte aujourd'hui une
ambition de réforme du marché européen
nous en avons besoin c'est une envie
c'est une évidence mais nous avons
besoin d'un marché européen qui
reconnaît le patrimoine national que
sont les concessions hydroélectriques
qui reconnaît la force française quel
est le nucléaire donc bâtons-nous
collectivement au service de la
souveraineté française merci beaucoup on
va s'arrêter là on suit ces questions
vous le savez sur LCP de très près il y
a une loi de programmation
énergétique qui arrive et vous serez
évidemment les bienvenus pour un
débattre vous restez avec moi Nicolas
Baverel dans une dizaine de minutes les
parties pris de nos affranchis ce soir
le regard de Raphaël Legendre sur le
mouvement social contre la réforme des
retraites 11e journée d'action
aujourd'hui celui de Vincent Huget sur
la visite d'État d'Emmanuel Macron en
Chine et puis Bourbon Express la niche
parlementaire écolo ce sera avec Elda
morengaba à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va plonger dans votre dernier
essai Nicolas baverest les démocraties
sont attaqués de toutes parts on le sait
mais avec le tournant de la guerre en
Ukraine et bien elle se défendent et
l'Ukraine résiste grâce au livret dont
livraison d'armes démocratique contre
empire autoritaire la liberté est un
combat on voit cela dans l'invitation
d'Hélène Bonduelle et on en parle
ensemble juste après merci
si on vous invite Nicolas baveray c'est
parce qu'on s'est en trouble sur la
planète vous affirmez que notre paix est
menacé les démocraties pensaient leur
sécurité et leur avenir garantie mais
voilà que l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie rebale 4
et les confronte selon vous plus que
jamais aux empires autoritaires
la paix qui dure depuis trois décennies
n'aurait-elle été qu'une illusion c'est
l'objet de votre dernier livre
démocratie contre empire autoritaire on
a cru qu'on entrait dans le
développement et puis la prospérité et
puis la paix éternelle en réalité on
verra avec le recul que cette période
89-202 n'a rien été d'autre qu'un nouvel
entre deux guerres et ça c'est une
remise en cause profonde
et ce n'est pas la première fois que
vous enjoignez les dirigeants
occidentaux à se réveiller Nicolas
baveray vous êtes historien économiste
éditorialiste et membre de l'Institut
Montaigne dans vos différents ouvrages
vous évoquez le déclin de la France
cette fois-ci il en va de la survie de
la démocratie de la liberté politique
le défi des empires autoritaires repose
sur la volonté d'éradiquer la démocratie
et surtout la détestation de l'Occident
au premier rang de ses empires
autoritaires la Chine et la Russie qui
ces jours-ci encore rappelé leur
coopération stratégique alors que le
dirigeant chinois se rendait pour la
première fois à Moscou depuis 2019
nous sommes partenaires dans une
coopération stratégique globale il doit
donc y avoir des relations étroites
entre nos pays nous avons de nombreux
stages et objectifs communs nous savons
que vous personnellement nos amis
chinois accorder une grande attention
développement des relations juste aux
chinoises face à cela dites-vous la
France doit se réarmer militairement
bien sûr mais aussi politiquement
moralement et intellectuellement alors
Nicolas baveray à l'heure où Emmanuel
Macron en visite en Chine rappelle à son
homologue si j'ai une ping
c'est pouvoir compter sur vous pour
ramener la Russie à la raison
nous avons une question pour vous
redoutez-vous réellement une troisième
guerre mondiale
réponse Nicolas baveray et bien il faut
évidemment tout faire pour l'éviter et
la meilleure manière de l'éviter c'est
effectivement que les démocraties
mettent en place une stratégie
d'endiguement de ces empires
autoritaires qui sont aujourd'hui décidé
à aller à les éradiquer une stratégie de
dissuasion militaire mais de refus
évidemment de l'escalade militaire pour
empêcher le la confrontation de devenir
ouverte également une stratégie de
dialogue avec les sociétés civiles parce
que on peut espérer que la Russie un
jour
boira le
putinisme comme elle a bu le communisme
et puis il y a un nouvel enjeu très
important qui sont les pays du Sud qui
aujourd'hui sont attirés par ces empires
autoritaires le sud global on va y venir
au fond si vous voulez c'est pour ça que
le réarmement et la meilleure manière
d'empêcher une nouvelle guerre mondiale
mais ce qui est intéressant dans cet
essai c'est que au fond s'est endormi
dans cette idée que ça y est on était
entré dans une sécurité une forme de
paix en Occident la fameuse fin de
l'histoire or vous vous dites au
contraire cette période là chute du mur
de Berlin 1989 jusqu'à 2022 invasion de
la Russie invasion de la crème par la
Russie c'était une période transitoire
au fond c'est une période d'entre de
guerre c'est ça oui c'est à dire que
clairement 2022 ça restera une année
historique c'est l'ouverture de la
grande confrontation entre les régimes
autorités et les démocraties et tout le
monde attendait que ça se passe plutôt à
Taïwan et ça se passe en Europe et en
Ukraine avec deux formes un conflit de
haute intensité en Ukraine avec un
niveau de violence de perte de
destruction comme on en a pas connu
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
puis il faut jamais l'oublier il y a une
guerre hybride contre l'Europe aussi
depuis longtemps cette guerre en fait
avec le gaz avec l'alimentation avec les
manipulations des flux de migrants avec
la désinformation avec les cyberatta qui
compris contre les les hôpitaux avec les
menaces aussi y compris
y compris y compris nucléaires ces
formes multiples de guerre les
occidentaux ou même les Européens pour
être on dirait non pas su la voir où
n'ont pas voulu la voir avant non on n'a
pas voulu le voir c'est à dire que on a
deux formes de somnambulisme il y a le
somnambulisme version le début du 20e
siècle où on voit pas la mécanique et la
diabolique des alliances et puis il y a
le seonnement Ulysse version années 30
ou parce que les démocraties sont
elles-mêmes tellement en difficulté que
elle n'arrive pas à s'unir et à répondre
à la menace à l'époque des états
totalitaires aujourd'hui ça a été ça a
été un peu la même chose parce que si
vous voulez
les guerres on en a faite mais ça a été
des guerres inutiles enlisées perdues on
peut le dire stupide c'est l'Afghanistan
on a perdu le contrôle du capitalisme
aussi en 2008 avec parce qu'on a cédé à
la facilité aux dividendes non seulement
de la paix mais de l'argent de l'argent
facile et c'est vrai que état
actionnaire entreprise consommateur tout
le monde a voulu vivre à crédit
vous voyez bien la situation prend
l'exemple de la Chine elle date pas
d'hier la détestation de l'Occident ça
remonte à quand précisément est-ce que
c'est la révolution populaire ou c'est
même avant le 19e siècle où il y avait
une domination anglaise notamment mais
européenne dans ces pays bien sûr il
existe en Chine un ressentiment contre
ce que les Chinois appellent l'époque
des traités inégaux et c'est vrai que la
Chine qui était une très grande
puissance qui est une puissance
millénaire pour rappeler qu'avant la
révolution industrielle la Chine c'est
de très loin la première économie du
monde ça fait 30% du PIB mondial en 1800
et ensuite la Chine a non seulement
décliné mais elle a été en partie
dépecée et donc ça que ce soit une
humiliation extrêmement forte pour les
Chinois que la Chine et que ce soit mis
du Parti communiste et d'avoir refait la
souveraineté oui mais une toute autre
chose est-ce que fait la Chine
aujourd'hui qui est elle-même de
s'inscrire dans une
projection de puissance impérialiste
avec explicitement dit par xigine depuis
2012 l'idée que la Chine doit dominer le
monde en 2049 et que dans cette
domination il y a effectivement non
seulement le supplanter les États-Unis
mais de bâtir un système de zone
d'influence ou la liberté n'a pas droit
de citer et ça ça pose un énorme
problème parce que comment ça va plus
loin que simplement deux blocs
l'Occident d'un côté la Chine et la
Russie de l'autre quand on parle du Sud
global on sent bien que cette position
anti-occidentale rassemble bien au-delà
de ces deux grandes puissances le sud on
le dit global en réalité il est très
divers mais le ressentiment
anti-occidental il existe il y a le
passé colonial il y a aussi des erreurs
c'est vrai que par exemple la manière
dont on a géré certaines situations de
surendettement également pendant la
crise de covid ou c'est vrai que une
fois qu'on a trouvé l'issue avec le
vaccin le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que on n'a pas fait grand cas j'allais
dire de de l'universalité de de la
pandémie il y a quand même eu un très
grand égoïsme enfin d'ailleurs les
démocraties sont même battues entre
elles pour être priorité et on peut pas
dire qu'on est fait grand cas du grand
cas du Sud donc si on veut discuter
parce que oui le problème c'est cette
fragmentation en bloc du monde mais qui
fait qu'on ne peut pas gérer les risques
planétaires on a parlé de réchauffement
climatique mais on a aussi donc des
problèmes stratégiques on a des
problèmes financiers on voit remonter
une crise bancaire on a le problème du
terrorisme tout ceci ça peut ça sera
beaucoup plus compliqué à gérer si on
est en bloc mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que il est très important pour les
démocraties de casser effectivement
se ressentiment alors contre l'Occident
vous parlez de reconnaître un certain
nombre d'erreurs peut-être qu'il va
falloir aller plus loin dans des
déclarations de dirigeants mais aussi de
se réarmer moralement
politiquement qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça alors ça si vous voulez ça veut dire
avoir une stratégie vis-à-vis des
empires autoritaires mais ça veut dire
aussi très de conscience oui mais enfin
la politique c'est pas seulement de la
prise de conscience c'est très important
la pédagogie mais derrière il faut
l'action on a quand même ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire on fait quoi une
guerre économique
il y a la partie extérieure mais il y a
aussi une partie intérieure c'est là où
la comparaison avec les années 30
fonctionne on a quand même des pays dans
lesquels on a profondément déstabilisé
la classe moyenne donc il faut
travailler sur les deux plans il faut
d'abord répondre aux problèmes
intérieurs des démocraties parce que le
moins qu'on puisse aujourd'hui une
partie des critiques qui leur sont
adressées sont juste par exemple
l'explosion des inégalités aux
États-Unis on a un niveau d'inégalité
comparable au 19e siècle c'est quand
même dans la plus grande démocratie du
monde et la plus riche une aberration on
a eu plus d'un million de morts de la
covid aux États-Unis alors que le pays
le plus riche du monde investit 18% dans
sa santé donc
il y a du travail chez nous et puis
ensuite il faut définir ce que
j'indiquer une stratégie raisonnable qui
permette d'endiguer ces régimes mais
sans tomber évidemment dans dans
l'escalade dans l'escalade militaire et
pour le sud c'est vrai qu'on est
beaucoup d'honneur de leçons je pense
qu'il faut écouter aussi ce que disent
les
les pays du Sud sur le réchauffement
climatique par exemple c'est vrai que si
on prend l'Afrique pauvres qui sont les
plus mais par exemple si on prend le
stock de toutes les émissions depuis
l'Afrique est responsable de 3% du stock
des des émissions et par ailleurs on a
aucune raison contrairement à un certain
discours malthusiens je ne vois pas au
nom de quoi on peut expliquer aux
Africains que c'est tout à fait normal
que la majorité de la population du
continent n'est pas accès à
l'électricité et que celle qui est accès
à l'électricité ou à l'eau c'est de
manière intermittente une prise de
conscience qu'un retour sur soi-même et
être capable aussi de tenir compte des
inégalités et des erreurs exactement et
donc
c'est un monde multipolaire il est hors
de question le but c'est pas que
l'Occident domine le monde on va avoir
un monde multipolaire on reconnaît les
autres mais on on se bat pour protéger
la liberté nos modes de vie et notre
civilisation parce qu'elle existe merci
beaucoup on va continuer à parler de
votre livre dans les chroniques qu'on va
accueillir tout de suite démocratie
contre empire autoritaire la liberté est
un combat c'est aux éditions de
l'Observatoire on va passer aux parties
pris de nos affranchis est-ce qu'ils
sont là nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris mais toujours pas non bah écoutez
il faut qu'ils arrivent
est-ce qu'on peut les faire entrer bon
bah écoutez je voulais qu'on vous fasse
réagir à allez-y on vous attend mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites elles a mon
dingava pour la chronique parlementaire
Vincent jeux voilà il vous allez pouvoir
réagir à sa chronique parce que elle
prolonge votre réflexion sur Emmanuel
Macron et son voyage d'État en Chine et
Raphaël Legent de l'opinion qui va
revenir sur cette onzième journée
d'action contre la réforme des retraites
Bourbon express pour commencer
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée par Elsa mondain Gava
bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais vous
raconter ce soir l'histoire du groupe
écologiste à l'Assemblée nationale qui
avait cette journée pour essayer et
c'est difficile quand on a un groupe
d'opposition bah de faire adopter des
textes de loi première tentative c'était
ce matin et ça a duré jusqu'en partie de
l'après-midi une proposition de loi pour
mieux manger l'idée c'était de créer une
prime alimentaire pour aider les ménages
modestes à lutter contre l'inflation
alors premier revers le gouvernement a
préféré sa version de moins ambitieuse
qui encouragent des initiatives locales
mais ensuite motive d'espoir pour les
écolos puisque contre la vie du
gouvernement deux amendements ont été
adoptés un de communistes 1 insoumis
pour bloquer les fruits des produits
alimentaires et des produits de première
nécessaire cité de certains produits le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques le député Renaissance
Guillaume kasbariian n'y va pas de main
morte quand il demande donc à
l'assemblée de ne surtout pas voter
cette proposition de loi ecoutez une
mesure communiste d'inspiration marxiste
qui est de dire que les prix
alimentaires doivent être bloqués vous
entendre cette proposition de loi
c'était les chars qui revenaient à
l'Assemblée nationale pas exactement ce
que j'ai dit je dis que le texte issu de
nos débat dans l'hémicycle n'avait plus
rien à voir avec les débats qu'on avait
eu en commission l'examen en hémicycle a
permis le passage de deux amendements
communistes d'inspiration effectivement
marxiste factuellement le blocage des
prix que vous pensez pas quand on leur
dit bah bloquer les prix les gens ils se
disent bah oui banco faut bloquer les
prix parce que maintenant les cours
c'est trop cher je m'en sors pas c'est
une très belle question économique la
réalité c'est que aucun pays qui a mis
en place le blocage prolongé des prix
n'a jamais réussi quoi que ce soit parce
que le blocage des prix à la fin c'est
des pénuries c'est des producteurs qui
produisent plus parce qu'ils disent
j'arrive pas à m'en sortir et au final
c'est des supermarchés qui sont vides
alors dans le texte il y avait aussi
l'instauration d'une deuxième
alternative végétarienne pour les
cantines l'interdiction des nitrites
très présent dans le jambon et donc
rejeter et rejeté description donc de la
rapporteur du texte de loi
est-ce que vous êtes déçu ou est-ce que
finalement vous vous y attendiez un
petit peu les deux j'ai envie de dire
les deux on est on est déçus parce que
voilà ça fait des mois de travail parce
qu'on a rencontré des acteurs locaux des
associations on a pris la température en
est conscient de l'urgence qui a
derrière ces questions de précarité
alimentaire de santé d'enjeux
environnementaux et en fait on fait face
à une action complète une action
complète sur ces trois volets donc on
est en colère on est déçu mais en même
temps on a envie de continuer le combat
alors les journées de niche
parlementaires il y a plein de
propositions de loi quel autre texte
pour les écolos aujourd'hui bien écoutez
il y a un texte qui vient d'être adopté
il y a quelques minutes c'était une
proposition de loi de Sandrine Rousseau
sur le retrait gonflement de l'argile ça
concerne énormément de maisons des
fissures elle propose de mieux
indemniser les propriétaires de ces
maisons et bien son texte a été adopté
il y a quelques minutes grâce notamment
on voit de la droite la droite qui vote
un texte de Sandrine Rousseau c'est
assez savoureux et donc un demi succès
donc pour l'instant une sur deux pour
les écolos tout à l'heure il y a
l'interdiction des jets privés il y a
aussi l'interdiction de la chasse le
dimanche alors là c'est en c'est terminé
à 20h elle va reprendre à 21h30 jusqu'à
minuit parce que les Nice parlementaire
c'est comme Cendrillon à minuit tout ça
arrête voilà c'est très économétré sauf
que la dernière on a un tout petit peu
dépassé petite anecdote ça s'est fini
autour de 20h15 c'était pas par
gentillesse pour les écolos non c'est
parce que le ministre qui était au bon
Jean-François combe il est arrivé un
petit peu en retard à la séance de 15
heures il était coincé à cause des
manifestations aux abords de l'Assemblée
les écolos ont donc rattrapé leur temps
et si vous voulez suivre les niches cet
après-midi ce soir pardon évidemment
notre équipe web suit tout sur le compte
Twitter LCP merci beaucoup Elsa
l'actualité sociale Raphaël s'est
évidemment cette onzième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites quel bilan ce soir peut-on
dresser 570
000 manifestants de partout en France 57
000 à Paris une mobilisation en baisse
entraînait de baisse c'est la moitié
deux fois inférieur à celle du 7 mars
des manifestations on en a pris
l'habitude malheureusement émaillée
d'incident notamment à Paris où l'on a
vu le restaurant favori des Macron la
rotonde en feu la devanture de la
rotonde en feu comme on le voit sur les
images et d'ores et déjà l'Inter
syndicale qui annonce une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation ce sera jeudi
prochain le 13 avril à la veille de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
la réforme des retraites alors le débat
maintenant et bien il a été lancé hier à
la sortie de Matignon par Laurent Berger
et ton en train de passer d'une crise
sociale à une crise démocratique et bien
personnellement je trouve moi qu'on a
surtout l'impression depuis trois mois
de vivre en pleine crise de déni de déni
du réel que ce soit du côté de
l'exécutif qui n'a pas été capable
d'expliquer la réforme à l'opinion que
du côté de l'opinion publique qui pense
pouvoir continuer sans effort
supplémentaire à bénéficier du régime de
pension le plus généreux d'Europe alors
ce soir je veux simplement rappeler
quelques évidences et clipser durant les
trois mois de discussion lunaire que
nous avons eu au Parlement alors quelles
évidence alors d'abord numéro 1 dans
tout régime par répartition un facteur
clé détermine tous les autres c'est la
démographie la démographie je vous donne
simplement un chiffre entre 2000 et 2030
le nombre de retraités en France va
passer de 12 à 20 millions c'est
quasiment un doublement en une
génération c'est une bombe démographique
qui va littéralement changer le visage
de la France et personne personne n'en a
parlé dans ses débats et ça va avoir
forcément des conséquences sur les
dépenses sociales et bien sûr une
explosion Myriam c'est pour cela que
rien faire serait irresponsable et cette
bombe on la connaît tout est chiffré les
tableaux sont dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui a
porté cette réforme que dit ces tableaux
en un mot que depuis 2019 les dépenses
sociales ont augmenté de 80 milliards
d'euros et que d'ici la fin du
quinquennat elles vont à nouveau
dépenser de plus de 80 milliards d'euros
cela veut dire qu'en 7 ans les dépenses
sociales vont bondir de 160 milliards
d'euros que sur deux quinquennat en
disant Emmanuel Macron aura augmenté la
dépense sociale de près de 200 milliards
d'euros alors même que les dépenses
militaires vont devoir elles-mêmes
doubler 413 milliards dans notre
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
pour la transition les dépenses pour la
transition environnementale écologique
bien sûr ce sera plus de 100 milliards
supplémentaires chaque année à un moment
l'argent je le dis tout de go ne tombe
pas du ciel si la France veut continuer
de voler en première classe et bien elle
devra payer son billet elle devra le
payer en travaillant davantage tout le
reste c'est de la littérature
si voilà une carte blanche un parti pris
signé Raphaël Legendre elle est
nécessaire pour vous cette réforme des
retraites il faudra travailler de plus
bien sûr ce qui a été dit c'est qu'on
peut pas avoir un système de répartition
qui est en déséquilibre puisque
contrairement à ce que les gens pensent
on ne cotise pas pour ça retraite on
paye pour la pour ceux qui sont en
retraite et une année et il y a les deux
données la démographie ça a été rappelée
l'autre grand
l'autre grande donnée ce sont les gains
de productivité et les gains de
productivité malheureusement il diminue
dans notre pays depuis 2019 et donc à
partir de là on a une activité et ce qui
est vrai aussi je pense que ce que dit
Laurent Berger donc c'est une réforme
qui est nécessaire et qui d'ailleurs
était par bien des côtés insuffisante
mais sur cette réforme nécessaire on a
effectivement greffé une vraie crise
sociale et une vraie crise démocratique
et vous n'avez pas peur de dire le mot
crise démocratique et donc il y a une
issue il y a une issue à essayer de de
trouver mais qui va qui peut pas être le
statut ni sur la enfin le statut court
réforme gouvernement
stratégie majorité si on laisse tout ça
en place il y a pas d'ici le 14 avril on
verra la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel alors on a gardé la
chronique chinoise franco-chinoise de
Vincent Hugier parce que forcément on a
envie de vous entendre sur sur Emmanuel
Macron face à chi-chipping c'est à VOUS
Vincent et bien fuyant le marasme
hexagonal l'Emmanuel Macron s'est envolé
mardi pour reprendre la tournure
golienne vers l'Orient compliqué avec
des idées simples alors l'Orient
compliqué soit pour ce qui est des idées
simples faut voir sur le front Russo
ukrainien postule le président français
Pékin peut jouer un rôle majeur dans le
tracé d'un chemin de paix en fait chemin
une ligne de crête étroite et piégeuse
en diable qu'importe la Chine est bien
comme l'avancée la seule actrice
susceptible de réfréner la fuite en
avant dévastatrice de Moscou encore
faudrait-il alors scénario crédible ou
pas illusoire si j'ai une pin ne lâchera
pas Vladimir Poutine pour donner corps à
son obsession faire au moins je égal
avec les États-Unis il a besoin d'un
obligé russe prête à lui céder pétrole
et gaz à ville prix mais certes pas d'un
vassal vaincu l'hypothèse d'une Chine
médiatrice et une chimère sont prétendus
plan de paix est une arnaque l'Empire du
Milieu n'est pas celui du juste milieu
Macron a péché par naïveté envers
Poutine il serait fâcheux qui cède à la
tentation de la candeur vis-à-vis de
Monsieur chi alors quels sont ces idées
pas si simple évoquées en préambule
l'Oscar de l'opacité revient à se
ténébreux mandra il ne faut pas se
désassocier de la Chine quiconque
percera le mystère de la formule gagne
une porcelaine de l'air Ming plus
sérieusement la troisième voie que Paris
préconise entre l'Impérium américain et
les appétit pékinois restent à dessiner
tout aussi ambigu le concept de
puissance d'équilibre que revendique la
France celle-ci n'a pas n'a plus les
moyens d'une telle ambition et de
équilibre par le ton faudrait-il pour
exister se tenir à mi distance de la
lier et de l'adversaire ça veut dire ce
voyage est inutile selon vous non bien
sûr en entraînant dans son sillage
Ursula vanderleyen la patronne de la
Commission européenne Macron a choisi le
bon format et déjouer le piège du tête à
tête inégal vu de Pékin la France n'est
que une des provinces du Vieux Continent
seul entité a même de lui tenir tête sur
le terrain économique notamment encore
faut-il qu'Emmanuel et Ursula laquelle a
osé Sommer la Chine d'un fléchir son cap
sur l'Ukraine parle d'une même voix
quand on invoque l'unité la tactique du
goodcom Bad Cop le bon et le mauvais
flic tourne à vide alors quelle trace
valait ce voyage de Pékin à Canton deux
événements survenus ce jeudi suffiste en
relativiser la portée d'abord l'envoi de
navires de guerre dans le détroit qui
sépare la Chine continentale de Taïwan
en riposte il va de soi à l'entretien
californien entre la présidente de l'île
insoumise et le speaker de la Chambre
des Représentants ensuite la rencontre
des ministres
où ça à Pékin là où fut orchestré le
mois dernier la normalisation amorcée
par les deux frères ennemis du
Moyen-Orient c'est assez dire que la
République populaire géant du business
prétendent aussi au statut de colosse
militaire et d'acteurs diplomatique
global l'ignorer nous exposerait à
découvrir à nos dépens que le jeu de
gogo le jeu de gauche
merci beaucoup Vincent c'est naïf de
croire que Pékin peut persuader Moscou
de bouger sur l'Ukraine je rejoins
l'analyse qui a été faite c'est-à-dire
que je pense que ça relève effectivement
de la Grande Illusion puisque très
clairement l'alliance entre la Chine et
la Russie devient de plus en plus une
alliance militaire que le plan de paix
le pseudo-plan de paix chinois est un
faux semblant ça revient simplement à
sanctuariser les conquêtes de Vladimir
Poutine et que le le
la Chine ne peut pas accepter la défaite
de la Russie
j'en profite par ailleurs du conflit
pour dans une relation très asymétrique
pour récupérer l'accès aux matières
premières et à l'énergie russe à prix
cassée d'un côté en même temps elle fait
très attention de pas se mettre de pas
refaire les Européens les Chinois par
exemple ont refusé le deuxième gazoduc
force de Sibérie parce que ils ne
veulent pas faire l'erreur des Européens
d'être complètement dépendant des Russes
tout l'importance de ce qui se passe
avec l'Iran et l'Arabie Saoudite en même
temps et derrière ça la Chine est quand
même en train de prendre le contrôle du
marché de l'énergie mondial et elle fait
une autre chose c'est qu'elle des
dolarise le monde puisque ensuite elle
installe au tour de tous ces accords un
pétrole yuan et avec l'idée de repousser
le le dollar donc merci notre président
bon on a compris qu'il va pas tout
changer en Chine au moins il vient avec
Ursula vanderlionne ça c'est bien joué
on pèse davantage à 27 alors
Ursula un discours qui est beaucoup plus
beaucoup mieux structuré
et beaucoup plus fort que le discours
d'Emmanuel Macron pour vous le discours
de Macron sur la Russie sur la Chine
comme sur la Russie si vous voulez le
drame c'est le drame du en même temps
qui est appliqué à la politique
étrangère on peut pas dialoguer avec
Vladimir Poutine et vouloir soutenir
l'Ukraine et et on ne peut pas derrière
il y a une incompréhension complète de
la nature de ces régimes et des de ce
que sont ces dirigeants pour en revenir
à l'Union européenne c'est plus
intéressant parce que là on a un vrai
levier on a un vrai levier pourquoi
parce que la Chine a un énorme problème
démographique entre le zéro covid et la
reprise en main de l'économie par le
Parti communiste en fait a cassé la
croissance chinoise donc on est passé de
9,5 à 3% et le seul vecteur de
l'activité aujourd'hui ce sont les
exportations et donc entre les
États-Unis et et l'Europe qui sont donc
détestés mais il se trouve que ça fait
150 milliards d'exportation pour la
Chine et il y en a 400 milliards pour
l'Europe donc
et derrière il y a des problèmes sociaux
en Chine il n'y a pas de suffrage
universel mais il y a une population qui
manifeste et qui est très présente donc
là dessus là dessus on a un vrai levier
et c'est la d'ailleurs où il y a aussi
un message qui est complètement brouillé
parce que on peut pas venir en voulant
jouer ce levier et avec 50 chefs
d'entreprise pour signer des contrats de
long terme au moment même où la plupart
des entreprises bien gérées quittent
plutôt la Chine pour
diversifier leur
réaction Vincent le chercheur Antoine
Bondaz souligne le fait que la volonté
chinoise de désoxydantaliser le monde
date d'au moins 20 ans ça n'est pas
d'hier deuxième élément là dessus on
s'aperçoit que l'ambition chinoise est
holistique l'idée d'une Chine géant
économique nain diplomatique et
totalement révolue les ambitions sont
3 registres l'économie la diplomatie on
l'a vu avec errant Arabie Saoudite et
également le militaire avec la montée en
puissance de l'armée de la République
merci on peut dire la technologie aussi
Qui est qui va avec
absolument avec l'humilité
c'est un défi ce qui est intéressant
parce que c'est là qu'on voit que c'est
un défi qui est encore plus compliqué à
relever que celui de l'Union soviétique
voilà et voir si on peut le relever et
bien on peut lire ce livre démocratie
contre empire autoritaire la liberté est
un combat c'est signe Nicolas bavery aux
éditions d'observatoire merci les
affranchis merci pour vos parties prix
et à demain même mieux même heure très
belle soirée sur SCP merci beaucoup
[Musique]